ben cardin the democrat the maryland
senator uh
very good to have you back senator uh
what's the likelihood we're going to see
a deal by late sunday night
well neil first of all it's good to be
with you happy holidays to you i hope
you're saying same as well i think it is
very
it's probable that we're going to get a
deal done i'm very optimistic
that we'll have an agreement uh reached
as early as today and voted on by
tomorrow
it's very possible i can tell you in
regards to the package that i've been
working
on small business we have completed our
work
so i i am optimistic we have one or two
issues that were
[ __ ] up to the uh the top leadership
they're gonna have to make decisions on
that
i expect as we're speaking now and put
this together
uh for floor action in the house
tomorrow
i i do want to agree with uh congressman
senator daines in regards to the process
this process is
just horrible we should be able to take
the budget up the appropriation builds
up these issues up
in a more deliberative way but this
is an urgent situation we've got to get
this done the american people
desperately need this covet relief all
right so assuming a deal is done i could
be just naive or overly optimistic but
to your point that the deal is scored um
do you think another deal will be
necessary that once
joe biden takes over um he's hinted at
the need for still more relief are you
in that camp as well senator
yes i do believe we're going to need
another coveted package this is
basically
a transition aid package to get us
through the next three months
we know that the impact of covet 19
is will be beyond three months from now
the impact it has on american families
and on our
our economy on state and local
government uh on
our health care system uh we're going to
still need to do
some extra work to make sure that we
recover from the scope at 19
uh in the strongest possible way
you know i guess there's been some a
division uh
on the the 1200 relief checks that we
saw back
in the early part of the vendetta i
guess right now senator might be more
like
600 and available to fewer people
i think the phase out would start at 75
000
and eventually run out altogether when
you hit 99 000
in income are you okay with those
provisions as long as stimulus checks of
any magnitude whether it's six hundred
or seven hundred dollars
go out remember this is a compromise
proposal in order to get it done and
signed by the president so that we can
provide relief now
uh it is not as large as i would like to
see in the package it does not include
direct relief to state and local
governments we desperately
the state and local governments need
that additional assistance
there is not enough resources here to
deal with those are unemployed beyond
next
the next few months so we're going to
have to come back to that
the direct payment check is is one half
the size as we did in the under the
cares act
but it's for a shorter period of time as
far as its
uh impact as to when we expect to get
the next uh package
under the biden administration so yes
i'm satisfied with the package
it's not the way i would have put it
together i would have done things
differently
but this is what we can get done and
represents the views
of both the democrats the republicans
the administration and congress
can you use this delay and because
you're
cooped up in the capital senator to tell
your loved ones look i would
i would i would have normally gotten you
holiday gifts but
i've been too busy in washington so is
it a good excuse for you
on case your loved ones are waiting for
gifts from you that they're not going to
get it this year because you've been too
busy working
neil i'm very fortunate first of all i
live in baltimore so i get home every
night
and i had to get eight gifts because we
celebrate hanukkah so
yes we've been busy in our family taking
care of our needs
but i'm one of those fortunate members
who every night can spend it in my home
that's pretty nice that's really nice so
that process is going on
with a couple of more nights on it so no
one's disappointed
on the home front right they're all done
right now
the hanukkah's over ended uh yesterday
so we're
we're now uh in the post hanukkah period
uh
but you know this is and your point is
well taken
we should have gotten this done a long
time ago it's desperate that we get this
need out here
we don't want the holiday to bring the
end of relief to those who are
unemployed
uh and not provide the resources we need
to get with people who are in desperate
situations
so we should have done this earlier but
let's get it done
uh in the holiday period let's get this
completed
but as uh senator dain said the real
gift is the vaccine that's coming let's
get this pandemic under control please
stay safe everyone we have
a few more months we have to deal with
this deadly virus
uh in its ability to spread very quickly
uh we all have to say very vigilant
in dealing with this virus all right
senator thank you very much and just
showing off getting your hanukkah gets
out and no
not not a bump in the process here now
i'm really feeling the pressure for
christmas so we'll see what happens
senator bewell have a very safe
holiday season